S
ALL THE TIME WE.
HAVE GREAT DISCUSSION.
THANKS.
AGAIN WE'LL DO IT AGAIN
SOMETIME.
AND FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP MAY
SOON BE BACK ON TWITTER.
THE OWNER OF, TWITTER ELON MUSK,
IS HOSTING A POLL ON HIS FEET
OF WEATHER TO REINSTATE THE
FORMER PRESIDENTS ACCOUNT.
THIS COMES AFTER HE AND BANNED
SEVERAL CONTROVERSIAL ACCOUNTS,
INCLUDING KATHY GRIFFIN, JORDAN
PETERSON, AND ALL OF QUITTERS
OFFICER CURRENTLY CLOSED --
AND A MASS EXODUS IS UNDERWAY
AFTER ELON MUSK'S ULTIMATUM TO
STAFF TO WORK QUOTE EXTREMELY
HARD-CORE OR LEAVE.
THEN SUDDENLY, YESTERDAY,
TRUMP'S CALL THE COMPANY
SOFTWARE ENGINEERS TO ITS
HEADQUARTERS FOR A MEETING.
KARA SWISHER, "NEW
YORK TIMES" CONTRIBUTING
KARA, YOU KNOW ELON MUSK.
YOU'VE COVERED HIM FOR YEARS.
LAST WEEKEND, YOUR CO-HOST TOLD
US YOU'RE ON THE SHOW AND ON
YOUR PODCAST THAT HE WOULD BE
SURPRISED TO TWITTER WENT DOWN
IN THE NEXT WEEK.
ARE YOU GOING TO SEE, THE WHALE
WITH THE LITTLE BIRD UP IN THE
AIR.
>> THAT WAS YEARS AGO.
THESE SYSTEMS ARE VERY
RESILIENT.
I THINK PEOPLE PANIC A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT, BUT WHAT COULD
HAPPEN IS IF HE STARTS TO PUSH
REAL CHANGES THAT COULD CAUSE
PROBLEMS.
IF THERE'S A MASS AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE, LIKE FOR THE WORLD CUP,
THAT COULD CAUSE A PROBLEM.
SOMEONE MAKES A MISTAKE, THAT
COULD CAUSE A PROBLEM.
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA SEE IS A LOT
OF PROBLEMS ON THE EDGES.
IF YOU HAVE TO FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION, A NEW SIGN OFF,
YOU CAN SIGN BACK ON.
OR WHETHER YOU WANT YOUR
ARCHIVES, IT'S HARD TO, GET IT
BECAUSE THEY'RE MOVING SLOWLY,
IF YOU GET IT ALL.
AS THE KIND OF THING YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE.
LIKE THEY BROUGHT KATHY GRIFFIN
BACK, BUT SHE SEEMS TO HAVE
LOST ALL HER FOLLOWERS.
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT HAVE
NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
THE WHOLESALE COLLAPSE, IT
CERTAINLY COULD HAPPEN.
BUT THERE ARE SYSTEMS AND
BACKUP SYSTEMS.
HE'S JUST MAKING IT RISKIER FOR
THEM.
>> WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM
EMPLOYEES STILL LEFT AT TWITTER
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING INSIDE
THE COMPANY?
ARE PEOPLE BEING LOCKED OUT AND
GIVEN MIXED MESSAGES AND SO ON,
THIS IS NO WAY TO RUN A
RAILROAD I THINK?
>> I THINK THEY THINK HE'S
MANIC.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
SOME OF THEM CAN'T LEAVE
BECAUSE THEY'RE ON VISAS SO
THEY MIGHT HAVE PERSONAL ISSUES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LEFT ON THIS
HARD-CORE SIGN FOR HARD-CORE OR
ELSE KIND OF THING.
I THINK 1000 PEOPLE LEFT.
AND THEY ALREADY CUT IT IN HALF
TO 3700.
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
A LOT OF THESE TECH COMPANIES
ARE SHUTTING WORKERS BECAUSE
THEY OVER-HIRED.
TWITTER'S BEEN FAMOUS FOR THE.
THAT, SAID HE DID IT
INDISCRIMINATELY IN ALL OF ONCE,
BECAUSE HE HAS SOME NEAT NOTION
THAT HE IS A A CHEMOTHERAPY TO
THIS COMPANY.
BUT CHEMOTHERAPY IS ALSO
POISON.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON.
HE'S DOING A LOT OF FORMATIVE
STUFF ABOUT TECHNOLOGY.
HE SHOWED A PICTURE THAT'S NOT
A CODE REVIEW, BUT JUST --
SO HE'S GONNA KEEP MARKETING IT
TO COST PEOPLE TO PAY
ATTENTION.
NUMBERS ARE UP BECAUSE
EVERYBODY LIKES TO TRAFFIC
ACCIDENT.
>> SO THE NUMBERS ARE UP?
THIS IS WORKING FOR MUSK WHAT
HE'S DOING RIGHT NOW DO YOU
THINK?
>> I DON'T THINK THIS IS GOOD
MARKETING, BUT EVERYBODY LOOKS
AT IT, LIKE DONALD TRUMP KNOWS.
THAT IF YOU MAKE NOISE AND YOU
CAN RAISE MONEY, YOU CAN GET
ATTENTION, YOU CAN GET THE
MEDIA FIXATED ON, YOU IT ONLY
HELPS TWITTER IN THAT REGARD.
I DON'T THINK IT HELPS IT FOR
GOOD.
IS NOT SAYING WHY IT'S A GOOD
PLACE TO BE.
IT'S JUST, SAYING WHAT A CRAZY
PERSON IS RUNNING.
THIS LOOK AT WHAT HE'S GONNA DO
NEXT.
UP --
>> HOW SENSITIVE IS MUSK TO
CRITICISM?
YOU REALLY RECENTLY GOT AN
EMAIL FROM HIM PERSONALLY ABOUT
SOME OF THE TWEETS THAT YOU HAD
SENT.
WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> WE'VE BEEN GOING BACK AND
FORTH FOR A FEW YEARS.
I'VE COVERED HIM FOR 20 YEARS
OR MORE.
HE WAS JUST ANGRY OF A TWEET
THAT I TWEETED FROM THE
WASHINGTON POST THAT ELON IS
GOING TO ELON.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT SETS THEM
OFF.
IT'S JUST LIKE.
THAT IS JUST MANIC.
MAYBE HE'LL START TALKING TO ME
AGAIN.
HE'S JUST LIKE.
THAT HE'S VERY THIN SKIN.
LIKE A LOT OF TECH PEOPLE.
IT'S ALL WELL AND GOOD WHEN
YOU'RE AGREEING WITH HIM, BUT
WHEN YOU PUSH BACK, THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH YOU.
IT'S ALSO PERFORMATIVE.
SOMEONE CALLED IT'S NOT
GETTING.
IT'S NOT MARKETING, IT'S SNARKY
MARKETING, SO IT'S SNARKY
EDDING.
>> HE HAS THIS POLL ON
RESTATING TRUMP.
I WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
I WAS THERE WHEN TRUMP GOT OFF
TWITTER.
I SUPPOSE THIS IS ONE POPULAR
VOTE THAT TRUMP MAY WIN.
WHAT DOES ELON MUSK DO AT THAT
POINT?
I SUPPOSE IT'S GONNA PUT TRUMP
BACK ON TWITTER.
TRUMP HAS SAID HE'S NOT REALLY
INTERESTED IN GETTING BACK ON
TWITTER.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S TRUE
FEELINGS WE DON'T KNOW.
>> IT'S ALL PERFORMATIVE.
THIS WHOLE THING IS
PERFORMATIVE.
OF COURSE HE'S GONNA PUT HIM
BACK ON.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE A
MODERATION COUNCIL AND HE PUT
PEOPLE BACK.
ON ANYTHING HE SAYS TAKE WITH A
LARGE GRAIN OF SALT, AND HE
DOES WHAT HE WANTS, HE'S THE,
OWNER HE, ONSET HE HAS A LOT OF
MONEY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
PRESSING DOWN ON, HIM IN A
POORLY AS A BIG PAYMENT SHOE.
HE'S VERY WEALTHY, ANY MAY
THROW MORE MONEY OUT, IT AND HE
HAS A LOT OF RICH FRIENDS,
BANKERS MADE THAT A MAUVE, BUT
HE HAS TO ULTIMATELY RUN A
BUSINESS AND HAVE PRODUCTS THAT
PEOPLE LIKE TO USE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON.
THE REST OF IT IS HAND WAVING.
IT'S JAZZ HANDS FOR
MILLIONAIRES ESSENTIALLY.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS,
LIKE MY PARENTS, THEY'RE NOT ON
TWITTER.
I SUPPOSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE --
>> NOBODY'S.
>> EXACTLY.
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT YOU ARE
NOW AND FOLKS IN OUR WOULD MAKE
SUCH A BIG DEAL ABOUT BUT IT
DOESN'T HAVE AS BIG OF AN
EFFECT ON EVERYBODY ELSE?
ANOTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS, WHY
CAN'T SOMEBODY COME UP WITH A
TWITTER THAT IS A GOOD THING
FOR THE WORLD?
LIKE WHERE WE CAN GO OUT THERE
AND SHARE INFORMATION, SHARE
NEWS?
TWITTER IS A GREAT THING FOR
LOCAL NEWS OUTLETS, NEWSPAPERS,
THAT SORT OF THING.
SO TWO QUESTIONS THERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> LET ME START WITH THE
LATTER.
THERE ARE LOT OF PEOPLE WORKING
ON HELPING IT ALL.
HE STARTED WAYS, POST START
NEWS, FOCUSED ON, USE AND
PEOPLE OF DIFFERING OPINIONS.
THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE
STARTING THINGS.
LOTS OF PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS AGAIN,
BECAUSE IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY IF
ELON FAILS HERE.
TWITTER IS A GREAT BRAND.
THAT'S ONE THING.
BUT MOST PEOPLE DON'T USE.
THAT IT'S MEDIA AND POLITICAL.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE ONCE TO
JUST AS MUCH AS YOU DO JIM.
IT LOVES THE THING.
--
IT HAS A LITTLE ECHO CHAMBER.
IN THAT WAY IT'S POWERFUL
BECAUSE THE POWERFUL USE IT.
CELEBRITIES DROP OFF BECAUSE
IT'S MESSY.
ADVERTISERS DON'T WANT ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THIS THING RIGHT
NOW.
IT PUNCHES ABOVE ITS WEIGHT.
IT OCCUPIES, IT LIVES RENT FREE
IN THE HEAD OF MEDIA AND
POLITICIANS, SO THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT.
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT WHEN IT'S
GREAT.
WHEN IT'S, NOT IT'S A CESSPOOL.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'VE GOT HERE.
IT'S A BAR THAT GETTING DICEY
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> WELL, WE ALL LOOK OUT FOR
THAT FAIL IN THE NEXT COMING
DAYS.
>> IT'S COMING.
>> ANYTIME YOU WANT TO COME ON
THIS OLD-FASHIONED TECHNOLOGY
CALLED TV, WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU.
>> IT'S.
AMAZ